Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
The author now the author of Alwaj here
now transitions into
what is most popularly mentioned by the
jerus the scholars of in their
respective books.
what is usually mentioned as a
followup to
the chapter regarding the invalidators
of those things which invalidate a
person's woo. If we were to review
those things which invalidate a person's
woo,
we said there are how many things that
invalidate a person's will?
Five. Five that the author mentioned.
The first
two
that which comes out of the front or
back private parts. Number two,
very deep sleep.
Number three.
No, we're skipping one. Very important.
[Arabic recitation]
Correct. Yeah. Passing out,
intoxication, loss of consciousness.
Okay. Number four, you said me
is touching the private parts, which is
a generalization. And if we were to
really be specific about it and really
only take the authentic narrations or
the best
chains of narration in this aspect which
none of them are very particularly
strong. we would say
is touching the for a man the penis
and for the woman her sexual parts
without a barrier of cloth or what
have you. And number five that the
author mentions
eating the meat of camel camel meat.
Okay. A person may say what about
vomiting?
Person may say what about bleeding?
A person may say
what about
is throwing up is indigestion.
What about
laughing and
what about we could say some of these
things are preferred
but obligatory. your woo is invalid. No,
it is only these five and even these
five have been highly debated as
we've mentioned in the past few days.
So it's only
reasonable that after mentioning what
definitely breaks a person's woo what
invalidates it
meaning you need to make woo
if you wish to make salah following one
of these five occurrences.
Okay.
Then the following chapter would be
that which is preferred a person make
wudoo following or that which a person
is encouraged to make wudoo following.
And there are many things in this
chapter such as vomiting. That's one.
such as
such as bathing or carrying excuse me
carrying a janaza or a dead person for
instance etc. There are many things
which could be preferred that a
person make woo but obligatory to make
wool is those three and perhaps four or
five. Even though when we look at
is more three.
What about touching the opposite gender?
For instance, these are things that are
purported or mentioned in the various
u mahib
that for instance a man touching
a man or touching a female skin-to-skin
will this invalidate a person's wudoo
right etc. Some of these things are
preferred that a person make wudoo after
such as vomiting or in the correct
opinion they do not break a person's
wudoo.
So he's going to begin with mentioning
that which a person must have woo to do.
When we say this is what breaks your
woo, you don't have woo after one of
these things occurs.
Well, what am I? What does that change
for me? What is it that changes in my
life with respect to the worship of
Allah between when I have wudoo and when
I do not? What may I do without wudoo
and what do I need wudoo in order to do?
The author mentions two things.
He says
the author only mentions two things and
this is a deviation from
and a deviation from the form
and what is known and accepted amongst
the vast majority of the scholars
there he mentions too there's actually
three.
The first one he mentions is salah. I
have to have to make salah. The second
one he mentions is I have to have to
make around the
What's the third one?
Handling the
handling the mus.
Now it is the opinion of a minority of
the scholarship of Islam
traditionally
that it is permissible to handle the mus
without wudoo. However, this is a
this is a weak opinion. one could say
very weak opinion and abysmally rare and
remote opinion amongst the scholarship
of Islam to the point that it's even
considered by some as
it is something which is so remote
that it's almost unheard of that the
major and jurists of Islam in the latter
years of scholarship ship have agreed to
and that is that you may handle the mus
without wudoo. But in the correct
opinion and again the form
is that a person must have woo to handle
the mus. Now notice the wording here
that we're using the mus not just
something that has
Quran in it. That's different. We're
speaking about that which is considered
the Quran. When we hold it, we say this
is the Quran,
right? And we'll discuss the parameters
of that inshallah.
[Silence]
and and so the first thing that a person
needs will do to do is salah that's
obvious that is something which is
it is common knowledge for the Muslim
however that is one number of
circumambulating
thea
making around the
due to the statement of the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam.
The prophet sallall.aii
said,
"Making
circumambulating the Kaa is salah. The
only difference between it and salah is
that a person may speak while making
wherein whereas in salah it will break
your it will break your salah to speak."
And so this is the second thing. The
third is
Quran and this is due to a narration
collected by
and im Ahmed and others that the prophet
Sam
wrote to one of his generals, one of his
commanders that
and no one is to handle or touch the
Quran except a person who is in a state
of purity. What does that mean? In a
state of purity.
[Silence]
of
and so when he says it is not
permissible, this is our prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam. He writes
it as a commandment to one of his
leaders. And no one who and and no one
who is not pure
ornone
is to touch the Quran except one who is
pure.
Pure. What does that mean? Pure is used
in the Quran and it is
in reference
or used as an opposite an antonym to
disbelief. So the believer is pure or
pure could mean someone who is not in a
state of major hadith janaba or pure
could mean one who is not in a state of
minor hadith meaning they have wudoo
which one of these is correct all of
them all of them
and so the point here is this is why alm
abuhaniva and malik and ahmed And when
we say these m these four are these the
only four in all of the history of
Islam. No m are very numerous and before
these four it were it was seven mib.
However knowledge becomes refined over
time and the evidences settle. If you
could imagine for instance
an arena where a battle is taking place
when the dust settles right it settles
with a few a few victors
and a few camps it was in the time of
the seven and later became four mahib
and these four mahib in addition to the
fifth mab which is the mhab
which is the mab of alkari Muslim Abu
Abu D etc. And then
and so
these four all agree that in order to
handle the mus a person must have woo.
Now what is the mus? What is the Quran?
Because we use words based on majority.
The ruling is the majority.
the majority of the contents of a book
if it is the majority the words of Allah
then it takes the ruling of the Quran.
So for instance let's say I had a a mus
and then in the margins there is
taps.
Which is it? Is this a book of tap or is
this a book
or is this the Quran? Well, it depends
on what the majority is. If the majority
of the book is the words of Allah, it is
the Quran with written in it. If the
majority of the contents are tap,
then it is a book of with Allah's words
me mentioned in it. Right? How do I
know?
How do you know? There's two ways to
know. Number one is use your best
estimation and judgment. Number two, you
could count every single letter that's
mentioned in the book and then write it
down and do that for all the books that
you have. And that way you'll know if
you need to have or not. I say this,
you're laughing, right? Cuz you're
thinking, who would do that? People have
done that. Yes.
which is a colossal waste of time.
Alhamdulillah.
Okay.